the wolf of wallstreet portrays a young
aspiring stock trader named Jordan
Belfort who makes tens of millions of
dollars from frauds and lives a very
extravagant lifestyle till he's
eventually exposed by the FBI and sent
to jail though the film at three hours
long provides an in-depth view of
Jordans lavish life it doesn't provide
much insight into how Jordan actually
made how much money we were simply shown
a montage from when Jordan starts strand
Oakmont in an old garage to exploding
into a large-scale securities firm so
what exactly did Jordan Belfort do and
why did it take so long to catch up
well starting off Jordan Belfort was
arrested on two accounts being
securities fraud and money laundering
securities fraud is how he accumulated
his wealth and money laundering is how
he made his money usable Jordan sales
experience actually dates far before he
delves into the financial realm his
first experience of sales was at a very
young age when Jordan and his friend
sold Italian ice treats to local beach
goers in their very first summer they
were able to sell twenty thousand
dollars worth of Italian ice treats
moving on in his early 20s Jordan began
a door-to-door of me telling business
and he was able to sell five thousand
pounds in just as the first week of
operation clearly Jordan was a very
talented salesmen and had been
developing the skill for several years
and he would end up employing the same
tactics in a securities company Stratton
Oakmont in his company his main money
creating strategy was using penny stocks
to his advantage penny stocks are stocks
of a company with a very low market cap
or market valuation often times these
companies are worth less than $100,000
as a result their stock trades for just
a couple of pennies technically a penny
stock can be worth up to $2 a share or
$5 in some cases to new investors this
often looks pretty attractive as you can
grow your money several fold
if the stock just rise a few cents for
example if you buy a certain penny stock
for two cents a share in yourself for 10
cents a share a week later you grow your
money fivefold but the problem with
penny stocks is that most of them will
never grow and there is no way to
predict which ones will grow as a result
banging penny stocks is basically
gambling on the stock market given these
concerns it is very difficult to sell
these stocks as these investors so there
is offer a large commission upwards of
50% one of the biggest questions that
surface is how the customers not notice
that these firms charge 50% Commission
well first of all during his time
internet was not something multiple had
access to so they can't just go and
check the current price online
furthermore these Commission's often
came from the seller side as opposed to
buyers
owners of pain stock companies would
sellers talk to security firms like
Stratton Oakmont for a huge discount in
order to motivate them to sell them to
customers and this is where Commission's
up to fifty percent came from this is
the money that Jordan sales associates
would make given the difficulty of
selling these stocks
Jordan hatched a plan to sell them to
cease investors after building
credibility what Jordan would do is
start off by selling blue stocks or
reputable company stocks to clients once
these mere substantial gain Jordan would
called his clients again and pressured
them to buy penny stocks and given the
gates to blue stocks investors would
often fall into a trap and buy into the
penny stocks Jordan would write scripts
that his sales so shi'ites would follow
allowing them make several grand every
single day rooms filled with such sales
associates making high pressure calls
are called boiler rooms and though some
sales tactics they employed may be
illegal for the most part though
ethically terrible this was perfectly
legal however this is not where Jordan
made his fortune
Jordan would use his boiler rooms to run
a pump and dump operation with penny
stocks you see penny stocks actually
have incredible potential it's their
unpredictability that makes them a
terrible investment but what if you
could artificially control their value
you could make millions very quickly and
this is precisely what Jordan did he
would buy big portions of various penny
stocks under different people's names
then he would get his sales associates
to go out and sell these penny stocks
this sudden increased demand would
skyrocket the price of the penny stock
at which point Jorah sell his shares
making millions when he cashed out by
selling his shares the stock price would
plummet cost his clients millions of
dollars using the strategy
Jordan was able to make upwards of 50
million dollars a year now a pump and
dump scheme is a serious securities
fraud and this is what the FBI was
looking cashed Jordan for considering
this ninety-five percent of business was
actually technically legitimate but
given the extremely shady ethical
behavior Stratton Oakmont federal
prosecutors and SEC officials denied
that Stratton Oakmont was a real Wall
Street firm
whether literally or figuratively in
fact that SEC was very keen on
investigating an activity going on in
strat Oakmont since it opened in 1989
but it was until 1996 that that firm
would officially be closed so why did it
take so long to bust jordan belfort well
as jordan didn't buy any Thea's penny
stocks under his own name and transfer a
lot of the money to Swiss banks it was
very difficult for the FBI to link any
of the money trails to Jordan Belfort
and build evidence against him given all
of this how did Jordan spend the
millions he made using pump and dump
schemes given that the FBI was tracking
him from very early on and how did the
FBI adventure exposed Trent oakmont's
underlying fraud if you would like to
know the major drop a like and consider
subscribing to see these questions
logically answered but until then I'm
Hari and I'll see you guys on the next
one